[Music]
in to infinity and beyond news story
okay submitted by the director of the
dome aliens Space Agency Oh
Jassa a Japanese billionaire will be the
first private tourist to fly to the moon
I saw this shit's crazy that is crazy
it's so next level you can't really have
any test flights right it's just like
there's no there's no there's no real
precedence I mean I do have a couple of
test flights but he's gonna be the first
one with like a human being on and he
just has big balls he's like [ __ ] it I'm
gonna just try the [ __ ] I think there's
a couple of other people that are gonna
be going on - yes oh this man this
billionaire his name is aku Muzzin
Misawa mm-hmm my Izawa maez
aid - ah WA now is our zawa zawa there's
just like Spanish it literally is yeah
yeah so she Asians similar he better
Cantonese - all right so this book are
not people Oh God this billionaire this
[ __ ] came out this fool
all right so here's a fool though he's a
dude he's a fool yes this Japanese
billionaire he's the founder of Japan's
largest online clothing retail called
dojo town and Elon Musk recently
announced that he will be the first
private customer to ride around the moon
for a week and they're projecting that
this trip will take place in 2023 so
crazy dude this guy's in his 40s - he's
kind of young I was like reading up on
him I was like damn dude net worth is
almost 3 billion I'm sorry it's more
than 1 it's 2.9 we have a dream that
whenever there's a Japanese billionaire
that I'm somehow related and then like
you know like those are those like
Nigerian scam emails like they're like
hey you're related to a prince I want
one email to come and be like oh you're
actually related to this guy and he's
reaching out to all the family members
and I'm like oh he wants to give them 5
million dollars yeah that's my dream
that's my dream yeah so this is what it
looks like they're saying that this is
what the trip would look like so it'll
go around earth how far is it gonna be
this way and then go around the moon and
then go back a week a week long trip if
I'm gonna spend that long to get there I
want to circle the moon a couple of
times that's just one loop and go back
home well on the contrary I value my
life and as this seems like it's an
experimental trip I would like to just
go there and perhaps come back I don't
want to spend any more time in the abyss
than I need you'll be kind of cool if
you spin and then you go off track and
you go off into space
albedo y'all come back here
you just slingshot away
and then what happens is like Inception
you get sucked into a black hole or
something that's a little scary that's
super scary it is but then the cool
thing is you'll be immortalized how do
you know that because people be like
remember mr. mysamma
remember how he [ __ ] must be people
who have have died in space that you
remember their name
I remember the [ __ ] Apollo 13 the
crew blew up so they're not immortalized
he's like Apollo Creed
the idea was Tom Hanks ah Hey Bruce
Willis they all died
you gotta do tommix was it an original
13 apology oh my god remember that [ __ ]
wouldn't win Apollo 13 landed on that
[ __ ] asteroid and they had to blow it
apart so there's a [ __ ] Earth
Sigourney Weaver dude I think my
favorite part about this story is that
like if anyone woke up mornings I want
to go to the moon we got to work their
whole life they're gonna become an
astronaut they've got to make billions
of dollars but this guy literally woke
up and he was like called Elon I want
the good I don't know why you just got
Russian that's pretty crazy long's going
with them too or he's like I don't even
trust my own [ __ ] you by yourself
initially he was like no this is like
his trip cuz misako he bought all the
seats on the bfr the okay okay
considering
Elon named his company the boring
company the original name of that rocket
is big [ __ ] rocket sure it was so
then uh yeah so lucky she's calling this
project
hashtag dear moon and he's saying that
he's gonna take six to eight artists and
so he wants to he wants this to be not
only did he buy just one got them all
and so he's like these are some of the
type of artists like he's gonna be
considering he hasn't picked anyone yet
that should tell so Elon he was he
convinced Elon to try to join him so he
was like yeah maybe I'll join you know
any other he needs to stay here you
can't you know if your watch you get out
two billionaires that yeah please don't
go we need you yeah because they did
mention that this is not a guarantee and
it's gonna take a lot of training for
all these people that are gonna be
joining him like that you know what
let's ditch the sculptor and let's add
in a youtuber cuz I want to watch the
vlog wouldn't that be that's true would
you guys go
I'm going I would not go space scares
the [ __ ] out I'll go and I hope I blow
up remember you video you guys are gonna
are you guys are gonna mageddon
know I've got a live stream but you guys
will have it so many views on my I'm so
sad videos when you vlog dude all I know
is if I see a news article that says
youtubers blows up in space I'll click
on that it's so fast I'm gonna set a
record and then we would probably do
that I'm gonna be immortalized yes crazy
that's better than [ __ ] being a
has-been in my face knees trying to try
to do a [ __ ] Vegas vlog show like I'm
like doing big huh okay nevermind I'm
good I'm gonna do it I'm gonna take the
be our big [ __ ] rocket though I wish
you shaped it like a dick that would
have been power yeah I was distracted
but that enormous flying Willy this is
the rocket back that can return like
it's the one that's our keep it can tell
you to know it's like the the one that
the Rockets like it's not as wasteful as
all the other rockets this one's like oh
okay because the other ones that go up
and then the other engines they just
fall off into the atmosphere space trash
this one it doesn't ask NASA always
throwing away to breathe trash poops but
us [ __ ] it the rocket goes up and then
they [ __ ] throw away all the [ __ ]
parts of the rocket all the trillions of
dollars go to waste
dude did he also consider that this is
basically real world in space because
you're gonna get like 12 strangers
picked to live in a space yeah that's
what's happening right now
like a drama I'm gonna be [ __ ] on
there and
would you miss the opportunity to [ __ ]
in space Oh every town I I just wanted
to say I'd do it you know you thought
but what I'd really like the August I'll
just start floating away just like there
gonna be a lot of S&M training where
you're like strapped to [ __ ] yeah they
do a porn in zero gravity or something
I think I remember reading I got branded
and zero gravity there's points of
gravity though cuz you don't have to do
that parabola yeah there's points where
you're like you're grounded and then
you're the zero-gravity and then you're
grounded again I wonder if the [ __ ]
just goes like ready for and then it
just and then it flies off to the side
and floats away just the chase it so it
hits her face yeah it gives a money shot
yeah but yes so they're saying that musk
said that
sokku he's the one that came to Elan
with this project idea and initially did
you guys remember that back in 2017 or
1617 they did mention that they were
gonna have citizens like just regular
citizens go up in space and it was gonna
be on the heavy Falcon which is a
different rocket and that they already
had two people that bought seats on that
rocket but then it turned out that they
cancelled that and then they changed it
over to the big [ __ ] rocket mm-hmm
well anyway he was one of the passengers
oh he's been those two passengers they
were kept secret we don't know what
happened to the other one
damn I wonder what it feels like to have
so much [ __ ] money and have
accomplished so much on earth that
you're like what else can i I need to go
to verdict at every single like thing
you can on earth II like yeah he might
be real estate scouting all right I feel
like artists I feel like if I was so
ballin though I still even if I was a
billionaire there's just so many things
I want to do on land that I don't even
think I need to get into space but that
was in there yeah that's thousandaire
thoughts my I would guarantee you he
hasn't done all the things I want to do
on man you don't really wanna do all the
things he's wanted
yes you real estate your mind gets blown
on a daily and this is like [ __ ]
peasant did you have a black belt in
jujitsu no what if he did all this like
what if he's been a billionaire for like
I don't know like ten years or some [ __ ]
and he's done a lot and then nice like
I'm a sober yeah next thing I can do
yeah he like underwater or something I
don't know jack Cousteau
actually no never run that's incredibly
dangerous James Cameron does he loves
underwater exploration that's what I
wanna do really like with the giant
squid SuperDuper the scuba certified
yeah deep seas kiss show yeah because
there is nothing on land that just
lights up except for like a lightning
bug you know like underwater like they
all that [ __ ] lights up I know but then
you're talking about space that's even
crazier at least here I'm still on her
go back to your question Jo because I
heard you say it really low but you're
like why artists yeah artists he said
that so he's an avid art collector so he
loves art in all shapes and forms and he
said this he was like what if Picasso
had gone to the moon or Andy Warhol or
Michael Jackson or John Lennon Oh
Michael Jackson what what about Coco
Chanel these are all artists I adore so
he's saying that what if they all got a
chance to go to the moon come back to
earth and create something magnificent
that would be like the biggest thing in
motion he stressed next level that is
the reason why he's picking only artists
like Meraki and artists tap into the
same creative like type of thinking so
people think entrepreneurs are like
businessmen but in reality they're not
as much because they tap into a more
like like a like a free thinking
creative mind because most entrepreneurs
cannot hold down things worth [ __ ] like
they need a whole team that's why they
build that around them and all that well
they're also thinking very innovatively
of things that don't even exist
yeah they're creating this world that
that no one else has even thought of
[Music]